deepmind builds a dense language model
with 280 billion parameters google
builds a sparse language model with over
a trillion parameters and microsoft has
a new dashboard welcome to ml news
hey there this video is sponsored by
weights and biases me and weights and
biases we've decided to take the next
step in our relationship and that means
i now have my custom link 1db dot me
slash yannick for all your needs i
actually don't know what's i'm going to
look it up after but there might be a
surprise who knows what's behind that
link the only way you're going to find
out is by going to it anyway today i
want to tell you about a new feature in
weights and biases so i've previously
told you about tables tables is this
very cool thing in weights and biases
that allows you to analyze your data
your models your results your outputs in
a table form but the table is like
interactive so the table can do anything
from filter and group to display your
plots play little sound files play gifs
and so on and it's just an awesome way
to look at your data from different
angles they have now added a new feature
to tables called the embedding projector
so whenever i wanted to look at some
sort of projection of my embeddings or
data i had to do that within the
experiment and then log that like as a
picture to tensorboard now tensorboard
has also gained some projector view but
this here is really cool so you can take
any table and any columns of those
tables as long as they're ins or floats
and you can use these projections to map
them to a two-dimensional space and then
look at them in 2d now for that you have
several algorithms at your disposal on
the left you can see a pca projection of
the digits to set and hovering over any
given sample shows you more information
in this case the sample itself in the
middle you see a u-map and on the right
is a t-sne you can interactively
configure these projections including
their parameters which columns are
included how the data is constructed and
much much more and these are interactive
like you can do anything here that you
would do in a regular interactive plot
and as always you can then pull those
into reports and show them together with
data or with some explanation and this
is just a really cool tool to do data
exploration or exploration of the
predictions of your model you can see
you have all the power available here of
regular weights and biases plots such as
color coding or intensity coding
whatever you want look at that isn't
that a data set oh t-sne what are you
doing now i absolutely invite you to go
check out weights and biases not only
for the embedding projector but as you
know they have tons and tons of features
for both practitioners and researchers
it's completely free for personal use
and academic use and no excuse not to
try it thanks again to aids and biases
for sponsoring this video and let's get
into it
deepmind releases a blog post called
language modeling at scale go for
ethical considerations and retrieval
that details not one but three new
papers out of deepmind gopher is a huge
language model and its biggest
configuration is over 280 billion
parameters that is almost twice the size
of gpt-3 now the authors here evaluate
the model on 152
diverse tasks and they achieve
state-of-the-art performance in the
majority of them the paper as you can
see is pretty long as it needs its own
table of contents but it's essentially a
big investigation into what these
language models can do what they cannot
do and how they perform in the
individual tasks the main interest here
is what happens if you scale these
models up what can you do and what can't
you do in the author's notes gains from
scale are largest in areas such as
reading comprehension fact checking and
the identification of toxic language but
logical and mathematical reasoning see
less benefit in order to train golfer
they also collect a new data set which
they call massive text it's a collection
of large english language text data sets
from multiple sources web pages books
news articles and code so not only do
the authors confirm that more text is a
good thing but they also confirm in
their studies in their analysis that
very much the quality of the input text
is just as important as the amount of
input text so cleaning the data and also
sampling the data according to its
quality makes a big difference in these
models the author's note we provide a
holistic analysis of the training data
set and the model's behavior covering
the intersection of model scale with
bias and toxicity now i have to say
something like bias and toxicity is
given a pretty big weight in this paper
i don't know why because it's an
investigation into many many things of
these large language models and i
personally don't see
bias and toxicity being like a
specifically bad problem that
specifically needs to be highlighted
it's not like we don't have enough
problems on our hands with the 151 other
problems but for some reason deepmind
chooses to highlight this one the blog
post also briefly goes into the main
results which were already mentioned in
this short summary but as you can see
right here gopher often beats gpt-3
however it's still behind human experts
in most tasks and when it comes to
things like scientific and mathematical
reasoning it actually just as gpt3 does
performs pretty poorly and purpose-built
systems to do mathematical reasoning
even though they are still lagging
behind human experts are much better
than something like gopher or gpt3 i
think this is to be expected as just
sort of picking up from language you
learn a lot of things like a lot of
factual knowledge about the world and a
lot of things that people say and
stories they tell and so on yet for
something like mathematical reasoning it
is not as much a language input thing it
is much more an algorithm that you have
to sort of practice over and over and
someone needs to show you how to do it
and and specifically essentially program
your brain to do an algorithm now i do
believe there's evidence that large
language models in principle can do
these things but what i'm saying is that
if you simply feed a large language
model a lot of data from the internet is
going to pick up on like common sense
facts a lot more easily than on
mathematical reasoning because i doubt
there's many websites that say you know
look here is how you do step-by-step
logical inference so the model
essentially would have to pick it up
through what amounts to reinforcement
learning whereas common facts about the
world they can just recite from some
website so is it the lack of appropriate
training data or is the model
architecture simply incapable of
performing logical reasoning i believe
the community is quite split on this
point and it would be interesting to
hear what you think the second paper is
called ethical and social risks of harm
from language models and is an
investigation a bit of a survey of
different areas of risk about these
language models the abstract says the
paper outlines six specific risk areas
discrimination exclusion and toxicity
information hazards misinformation harms
malicious uses human computer
interaction harms and automation access
and environmental harms the most
interesting paper though is the last
paper it's called improving language
models by retrieving from trillions of
tokens there is a special blog post to
go along with the paper if you want a
shorter more condensed version but in
essence this is a language model it's
called retro that not only does it
produce language but as it produces
language it is able to go to a database
of things that it can retrieve so in
this database you can put all of
wikipedia here they say github books
news and so on essentially whatever you
would usually train on so your training
corpus you also make it indexable via a
lookup index then as you train your
language model in each step of producing
the next token what you do is you take
the current input or whatever you've
produced so far you go to that database
you retrieve the nearest neighbors of
whatever your input is so far and these
nearest neighbors you retrieve with
something like a pre-trained bert
embedding model i guess you could also
do some tfidf things so you want to get
the sort of closest neighbors out of the
training data set or the whatever
database you have and then you provide
those to the language model as
additional reference to take from the
paper introduces a special chunked
attention model such that it can
actually refer to these individual
passages that the retrieval step takes
out without having the quadratic memory
blow up of attention and as you can see
it interleaves self-attention layers
like in a regular transformer language
model with these cross attention layers
that now attend to the retrieved things
from the database the result is pretty
astounding as they say they can achieve
sort of the performance of these large
language models while having much much
less parameters and it seems what's
happening here is that we always used to
think that for these large language
models you had to scale the data up so
they know more stuff or can do more
things but in concordance with scaling
up the data you also had to scale up the
model because what we do during training
is kind of we take the data and we sort
of embed the data into the weights of
this neural network by training it right
the reason gpt3 knows so much is because
we've baked all of this knowledge into
the weight somewhere so gpt3 not only
has the rules of how to produce language
but also sort of the the knowledge that
it will produce all in its weights so we
always use to scale data and model size
and compute at the same time now it
seems possible and that's what this
research shows that you can in fact take
some of that data and sort of decouple
it from the model size and the compute
that you put in by supplying it at
essentially inference time so now the
language model can be much more focused
on how do i need to construct language
it may have a little bit of knowledge in
there but it can always look up more
knowledge at inference time and use sort
of that to produce the output the paper
goes into more details about the
architecture the chunked attention
mechanism and much more stuff but what's
also pretty cool is that you can if you
want take just this transformer this
language model and use it as a regular
language model by not retrieving
anything and that seems to work okay-ish
so even if the model cannot retrieve
something it's still able to give good
outputs not perfect not the best but
good and conversely it also seems to be
quite easy to take a pre-trained
language model and augmented by such a
retrieval mechanism so to what they call
retrofit it which is a wordplay because
their model is called retro so this is
like this is like a dad joke that's been
in the making for
you know nine months or so so i i hope i
hope you enjoy this moment where you can
say look we retrofit the model but it is
pretty cool though you can take a
language model that's been pre-trained
and with a bit of fine tuning it seems
you can make it use this this uh
retrieval mechanism and therefore you
can supply it with much more data that
has been trained on this can also be a
method to keep these models up to date
because you know the training data set
gets older by the day by definition and
instead of retraining you might be able
in the future to just switch out the
retrieval database and therefore keep
the model's outputs up to date all in
all pretty cool if you are interested
check out the blog post the papers and
deepmind no affiliation
leandro fonvera has a blog post on the
hugging face blog called training code
parrot from scratch where he goes in
detail in through how you can train your
own model that is like github's co-pilot
so it takes your code and it suggests
what next code you want to write now
co-pilot by itself is an amazing system
and obviously there's there's a lot of
engineering behind it there is way more
parameters than you could ever train but
if you want to train a small model from
scratch or from a checkpoint this is an
excellent insight into how this is done
so it goes through everything getting
the data cleaning the data training a
tokenizer for code actually training the
model evaluating it and everything it
shows you how to do some optimizations
like how you can make everything a bit
more efficient by concatenating
different samples so you always fill out
the context shows you what you need to
pay attention to when cleaning the data
set turns out on github very very many
files are actually duplicated and that
really hurts training performance goes
through hyper parameters it goes through
data parallelism and optimizing your
training code and it's just super
detailed so here you can see for example
the comparison of the accuracies and the
code para models even though they're
quite small they do actually get some
significant-ish performance now it's
nowhere near open ai's codex model which
is the model powering github's co-pilot
supposedly but it still you know does
something and that's pretty cool so here
you can see an example of this so the
prompt is a function definition called
is even that returns true if a value is
an even number and then the model is
asked to set up a unit test for is even
and as you can see right here the
completion that is given not only is it
the correct name it has a good docs
string but also it actually tests the
function in question and it doesn't
really you know get what it's supposed
to do but still the structure is sort of
already there so you could you know just
assert like false right here but as we
know these models really shine when it
comes to like knowing how to handle uh
apis of some libraries and so on because
supposedly these libraries either
themselves are on github or there are
many code projects that already use
these libraries so the models would
essentially know how to use the
libraries and what functions to call and
so on here you can see that the model is
perfectly able to build a bird
classifier i guess you know this is also
a bit of a shill for hogging face
because it just takes two lines of code
with their code base but still models
pretty cool so if you are interested
definitely give this blog post a read
there's a paper out of mit called
learning to see by looking at noise and
this paper questions the paradigm of
pre-training on data by switching to
pre-training on noise and they actually
get some pretty decent results they do
investigate different styles of noise so
there is procedurally generated noise
statistical noise there is initialized
style gun so non-trained style gans
where you simply forward past data and
what comes out you take as training
images and there is also feature
visualization procedures of trained
models now here you can see in dark the
actual pre-trained models on real images
and you can see that the models that
have been pre-trained on noise aren't
that far behind especially interesting
is that stylegan models just initialized
randomly and then four were propagated
give pretty decent results now these
results are on pre-training on a data
set and then linearly adapting these
models to imagenet which is obviously
not the most performant thing to do but
it gives sort of a baseline also
interesting is that apparently minecraft
images also do quite well there's much
more to this paper including feature
visualizations evaluations and so on if
you're interested paper code and data
sets are available
deepmind has another blog post called
simulating matter on the quantum scale
with a i now i have tried reading
through this paper and even through the
blog post and honestly i have no clue of
anything quantum like quantum chemistry
anything like this this is just beyond
me but this paper deals with the
prediction of where electrons are in a
molecule so it turns out you don't
actually need to track the individual
electrons you just sort of need to track
the density function of where any
electron could be at any time and in
order to predict that various
approximations and heuristics are used
and turns out that if you use machine
learning and a little bit of very clever
data engineering and feature engineering
then you can come up with a system that
outperforms any of these previous
systems now again the paper's been
published in in science i have no clue
what any of this means if you do and if
you're interested go check it out
google ai publishes a blog post called
more efficient in context learning with
glam this goes along with a paper called
glam efficient scaling of language
models with mixture of experts this is a
model that is over a trillion parameters
in size now this is a sparse model so it
is not directly comparable to whatever
the 175 billion parameters of gpt3 which
is a dense model so in a sparse model
what you do is that in the feed forward
layer of the transformer layers you
would not activate all of the feed
forward layer for every token but you
would route the tokens to one of many
what are called experts so these models
are generally called mixture of expert
models so the idea is that you have this
gating layer and the gating layer
decides which of the experts become
activated this results in each token
only activating a small part of the
network which makes it way more energy
efficient to actually forward propagate
at inference time also makes it faster
and with the current hardware and
algorithm optimizations that the google
ai team has put in here it does require
more flops at training time because it
trains on a way larger data set than
current dense models however it does
require actually less electricity and
that's pretty cool i guess it's a little
bit that you're trying to find some kind
of a metric where you're better than
anyone else but i do find it cool that
both at inference time and in terms of
training energy consumed this is
actually the preferable model now it is
huge and you need a huge architecture to
train it but i think that counts for all
of the models currently they do have a
lot of investigations into comparing
dense and sparse models and they do
generally find that the sparse models
outperform the dense models given the
same amount of training tokens and their
final model outperforms gpt-3 on a
number of natural language tasks so
pretty cool if you're interested check
out the paper
colin rafael releases a call to build
models like we build open source
software this is a blog post with a
general appeal to the community where he
first lists a bunch of the advantages of
open source software versus closed
source software and a bunch of features
of open source development such as
version control submitting patches and
poll requests merging semantic
versioning compatibilities and so on and
then he tries to make analogies to how
we could develop models so at the end he
has this paragraph right here where he
details how a potential future could
look so this says researchers at
sullivan university decide to train a
new language model called clamp they
have limited access to computational
resources so they are only able to train
the model for enough time to attain
reasonable performance on a few
downstream tasks after fine-tuning they
set up a framework for testing the
model's fine-tuned performance on a
suite of downstream tasks and release
version 1.0.0 of the model to the world
later a different group of researchers
at the university of duxville make use
of their computing cluster to perform
additional training the user training
method that only updates a few of the
model's parameters so that they can
cheaply communicate the proposed changes
back to clamps maintainers the new
model's performance is rapidly verified
on the task suite thanks to the ability
to reuse updates from previous
fine-tuning run however it turns out
that the fitmore foundation has also
been performing additional training in
parallel fortunately the updates by each
organization can be merged and they are
included in a new release of clamp in
version 1.0.1 and it goes on so this
tries to make a bunch of these analogies
and i have to say some of them are
pretty accurate and would be like nice
to have especially sort of this
collaborative development of models you
release a checkpoint someone else
improves upon it you sort of merge this
together and so on you raise like a pull
request on a model but some of these are
a little bit more shady like you would
only update a small part of the model
because that makes it cheap to
communicate usually the communication
overhead is in like distributed training
where you need to communicate thousands
and thousands of time that's when it
matters but when i train a new model and
i like raise a pull request i don't
think it matters whether i have 40 or 60
gigabytes of weights that i want to
merge into the different model also sort
of this notion of backwards
compatibility i think is a little
different in real software versus uh
versus models and the only true example
uh colin gives here is that the model
would still take the same inputs and
give the same outputs but that honestly
that has nothing to do with machine
learning that is again like that is a
regress to to actual software
engineering right that would be using
our old systems for software engineering
and
in between somewhere is a model so it
might be a bit of a a sort of forced
analogy at some places but i do think
it's pretty cool and i do think uh new
paradigms of how we develop models
together especially as opposed to a few
companies internally developing these
huge models just in silos and then
selling them via apis but a few things
are in the way most notably the very
very often requirement to train things
end to end which sort of makes this
whole you know modularity among models a
bit tricky if you want to read the whole
blog post feel free to check it out
ernest david releases a paper and
archive called deep learning and
mathematical intuition a review of david
zedal 2021 this is a response to
deepmind's paper about using deep
learning in fundamental math now ml news
has reported on this with our outside
reporter marcus betting last week and
this paper kind of criticizes the hype
around this this math paper now fair to
say this paper has been kind of
overblown in pop culture like oh ai
solves math and whatnot i mean my own
thumbnail was a click bait for exactly
this but i just want to draw attention
to the abstract here in the not theory
result the role of deep learning was
small and the conventional statistical
analysis probably would have sufficed in
the representation theory result the
role of dl is much larger however is not
very different in kind from what has
been done in experimental mathematics
for decades moreover it is not clear
whether the distinctive features of deep
learning that make it useful here will
apply across a wide range of
mathematical problems finally i argue
that the deep learning here guides human
intuition is unhelpful and misleading
what the deep learning does primarily
does does primarily does is to mark many
possible conjectures as false and a few
others as possibly worthy of study i
don't think deepmind has actually said
anything else
like just the amount of salt in this
abstract is
i haven't actually read the paper so the
paper could be uh totally
sane and reasonable but it the salt here
is i can taste the salt through the
internet but i'm sorry if a conventional
statistical analysis would probably have
sufficed then why didn't you do a
conventional statistical analysis why
aren't you going out and doing
conventional statistical analyses
getting more fundamental theorems or
more results in mathematics now wouldn't
that be like a better use of your time
no i'm obviously like it is important to
also criticize in academia i think that
that is a healthy part of the ecosystem
but let's be honest this paper has
mostly been overhyped by media and the
paper itself has actually stated fairly
accurately what the contribution of deep
learning was so i doubt that an academic
paper is the correct refutation to media
hype i think that refutation has to
actually just come from other media but
if you're interested in a more sober
analysis and maybe a little bit of salt
give this paper a read
okay some helpful things for this week
transformers has a new release with lots
of updates version
4.13.0 is out and has a lot of new
models such as segformer imagegpt
diberta v3 and the trainer now supports
bfloat 16 numbers excellent cohere ai
releases a really really nice basic
introduction to prompt engineering where
they show how to engineer prompts for
very different tasks and what has
generally worked in the past to give
good outputs of these language models
that you can query using in context
learning check it out they not only have
posts on prompt engineering itself but
also how to handle temperature or how to
set top k and top p variables and so on
excellent not really machine learning
thing but github improves its code
search i have been previously not so
happy with github's code search and they
have a bunch of updates a bunch of
keywords you can use a bunch of filters
and drag x's and so on and i'm quite
happy about that so i thought i'd share
it with you hugging face introduces the
data measurements tool it's an
interactive toolkit for looking at data
sets this is a tool to do some basic
investigation into data sets like show
summary statistics uh drill down into
some distributions like word count
distributions see if there's anything
off if there's anything over or under
sampled look at associations between
words and samples and so on and the goal
is i think to also make this into a tool
where you can create new data sets
pretty easily the data measurements tool
like everything else is available on the
hogging face hub as a space very similar
microsoft releases a responsible ai
dashboard that has various tools to
analyze the outputs of your models and
whether or not they conform to some
standards where the most mistakes are
made and really drill down into
performance issues so here are a few
things it supports error analysis model
interpretability data explorer model
statistics counter factual analysis
causal inference what if questions and
more this is important especially for
practitioners that are trying to
actually build real products and need to
diagnose various failure cases that
might not necessarily be covered in the
training data sasha roosh releases mini
torch this is a tutorial-ish
bookish thing where he goes through a
building torch from scratch or something
like torch so in this tutorial
you'll learn about mathematical
operations how you can build up a system
that does auto differentiation how you
can build up a tensor class yourself how
you make everything more efficient and
so on and there is a github repo to go
along with this if you just want to skip
to the end or if you want to follow
along excellent the pandas tutor is an
introductory tool to pandas that lets
you understand how pandas transforms
your data so in here you'd put your
pandas command your your python code
that operates on pandas data frames and
it would show you line by line what
happens to your data so here is a data
set of dogs if i go down you can see it
recognizes the first operation is
filtering by a boolean mask and it shows
me exactly what's happening in my data
frame with a nice visualization and even
a little bit of animation the second
line is a sort so it shows me what thing
it sorts by shows me where every data
point is going then there's a group by
and finally a median which are
visualized using colors and again a
bunch of arrows they do have more
visualizations than just arrows and
colors but this is just an example if
you're new to pandas and try to
understand what a given piece of code
does or try to debug some kind of a bug
that you have this might be a nice place
to look yuno is a search engine that
given a description gives you an
appropriate anime to look at i am not a
big watcher of anime but if you are this
might be just the tool for you though if
you are a big fan you probably already
know all of them so you know but it's a
cool project uh the author describes in
detail in how this went about there's a
lot of analysis of the data set the code
is available there's a collab where you
can try it out so here is an anime where
the main character is very smart but no
one knows about it you can set a slider
for curiosity and you get various
suggestions the us bureau of reclamation
has a competition where you have to
predict how much water is released from
snowpack so this is a really important
measurement because during the winter
snow falls into the rockies and then
during the spring and summer it melts
off and provides all the fresh water to
essentially the western part of the u.s
mainly and predicting where how much
snow is and how much of it is going to
melt is very crucial to planning ahead
there's actually 500 000 dollars to win
right here this is split up so the
overall winner gets 150k but if you are
also the best in various regions you can
collect prize money from each of the
regions and there's also prize money for
the best report so yay reddit user arno
wakzinski writes the story about
creating an alpha zero-like solution for
playing ultimate tic-tac-toe in the
browser this user did not know anything
about web development when they started
and it has resulted in a website where
you can actually play this game now i
didn't i didn't even know
uh what what this game was but it's a
very interesting game so you play
tic-tac-toe but it's it's sort of a
super grid superimposed and um your
opponent will be able to play in the
subgrid of sort of the cell you select
right here so if i select this cell the
opponent will be able to play in this
cell the next move so you kind of need
to plan ahead and then if you win let's
just let's just screw up horribly right
here let the opponent kind of win
again in this cell right so if the
opponent wins down there then it's not
over but you sort of have to not only
win the small games you have to win like
the super games this this is just for a
human this is crazy
and uh this user has developed a and
sort of an alpha zero like ai for this
and the development is really nicely
documented so if you want to give it a
try or if you want to follow sort of the
development of this uh check it out nl
augmenter is a framework for task
sensitive natural language augmentation
and as you can see it has a bunch of
authors i'm reporting this because i've
previously shouted out this project and
i think it's a pretty cool initiative
the paper has collected augmentations
natural language augmentations from all
users and anyone who submitted one is an
author on the paper now whether
authorship is meant for that i don't
know but you know if the foundation
model team can do it then certainly this
is justified the final library of nl
augmenter is available on github and as
far as i know still being extended very
cool and lastly there is a collection of
33 psychology related data sets user
yumkwe writes on reddit this is by the
website open psychometrics and if you
are interested in psychometrics and
learning from that data this might be
just the opportunity for you
[Music]
swiss info writes sarco suicide capsule
hopes to enter switzerland now this
seems horrifying by itself but it was
actually more horrifying initially there
is a long fact check along editorial
note that the article was changed it
originally said this already passed
legal review and that it works with
various organizations within switzerland
which is not the case the capsule wants
to enter the swiss market and is
currently in the process of entering the
market as you know in switzerland
assisted suicide by choice is legal and
there are organizations that sort of
consult with you and you have to justify
to them why you want to go through with
a suicide usually it's because you're
terminally ill and you don't want to
cause your family more trouble than
needed as far as i know they do have a
pretty high bar for when they will
actually go through with the procedure
this company seeks to replace that
with the capsule so here's a description
the person will get into the capsule and
lie down is very comfortable oh gee the
things is very comfortable
they will be asked a number of questions
and when they have answered they may
press the button inside the capsule
activating the mechanism in their own
time at that point the oxygen will just
be reduced and you'll fall asleep and
die like i have no trouble with the
method of dying right but they say our
aim is to develop an artificial
intelligence screening system to
establish the person's mental capacity
naturally there is a lot of skepticism
especially on the part of psychiatrists
yeah you think
but our original conceptual idea is that
the person would do an online test and
receive a code to access the sarco oh
wow so right after i take the online
test for what's your cheese type
i could also take the online test to get
into the suicide machine i mean i have
to say it is a tricky subject right
because you want to give people this
opportunity but also if if you think
that there's an easy way to sort of
assess consent and mental state it is
also a big underestimation of how for
example depression works and and what it
actually does to you and your mental
state so even though you might be sort
of conscious and and legally allowed to
make decisions it is still very very
tricky now i'm generally of the opinion
that in principle in principle it might
be possible that an ai system might be
on par with a psychiatrist in assessing
said mental state but i don't think
we're gonna be there like right now or
in the near future but who knows uh
maybe you'll end up in one of these pun
intended
[Music]
and lastly techcrunch writes synthesia
raises 50 million us dollars to leverage
synthetic avatars for corporate training
and more synthesia is a company that
creates these virtual avatars so here is
the three-step process select your ai
presenter type in your script and get
your video excellent now i'm absolutely
for not actually needing to portray a
human face anymore with this like either
you hire an actor or someone company
internal needs to do it and then their
face is somewhere recorded and so on so
i can totally see why this is appealing
ironically the little chat that popped
like who who who makes these chats who
thinks these chats are a good idea like
i've never ever ever entered anything
into a chat that pops up on a website
ironically the person in the chat as you
can see
is one of the one of the avatars
so the company goes full meta right here
in that the salesperson selling you the
virtual avatars is a virtual salesperson
excellent now of course these virtual
avatars are useful in certain situations
though it does seem a little bit
dystopian it also does seems that other
industry notably the adult industry
might profit quite a bit more from them
but who knows maybe there will be sort
of a lash back and the desire for real
humanity and actual imperfection and the
most desirable actors will be ones with
scars and no makeup and dirt and
disformed faces and anything and
everything that shows that they are not
ai created though i have my doubts about
that all right this was it for ml news
thank you so much for listening watching
please check out weights and biases
thank you so much for sponsoring this
video and remember to keep your
gradients
low
bye
[Music]